staying in Ukraine shows that the United States is
trying to prolong this conflict and
in the same way they are acting, burning
out the conflict in Asia and Africa and Latin
America,
as you know, I recently heard once
again deliberately tried to add fuel
to the fire and rock the situation in the
Asia-Pacific region
American adventures in relation to this
unnie this is not just a trip of an individual
irresponsible politician, but part of a
purposeful conscious strategy of the
United States to destabilize and, although for the
situation in Riga, a blatant demonstration of
disrespect for the sovereignty of other countries and
for their international obligations